today i'll be talking about the clc
um portfolio specifically for the kaijan
genomics pro suite
software uh the latest version version
20 which was released in january of 2020
and the kaijan genomics pro suite
includes
uh four different products uh the
clc genomics workbench the clc microbial
genomics module
and the clc genomics finishing module
actually it's three products um so
before i get started
um we have a small legal disclaimer
the hydrogen products shown here are
intended for molecular biology
applications
only they are not intended for
diagnosis prevention or treatment of
disease and for up-to-date licensing
information and
product specific disclaimers please see
the respective kaiju kit handbook or
user manual
including our documentation on the
software on our website uh
kaijen kit handbooks and user manuals
are available at www.kyogen.com
or can be requested from our technical
services or your local distributor
go ahead so the kyogen genomics pro
suite uh
combines multiple capabilities together
for laboratory scientists and
bioinformaticians
to efficiently conduct their
bioinformatics analysis
on both nation sequencing data as well
as sanger sequencing data
and to do classical molecular biology
comparative genomics types
of research the key functionalities of
the software include genome assembly and
annotation tools
strain typing and characterization tools
for bacterial isolates
and viral pathogens as well microbiome
analysis
including both 16s and shotgun
metagenomics
and it integrates seamlessly with the
clc genomic server as well as the
clc genomics cloud engine
so the microbial genomics module
specifically
includes the capability to do strain
typing epidemiology
for taxonomic identification of isolates
typing in phylogenetics capabilities
multiple approaches there
including the ability to identify and
construct sniff trees
as well as camera-based trees and to do
minimum spanning
trees as well from both mlst
and core genome or whole genome mlst
data
recently we updated our microgenomics
module to include
poor genome and whole genome mlst strain
typing capabilities
and i'll be doing a very brief live demo
of what those trees look like and some
of the functionality that's included
there
we also include the ability to download
uh
multiple publicly available
antimicrobial resistance databases for
analysis of your
isolates and kaijen also maintains
a integrated database called the
hydrogen microbial insights database
which integrates both
card argonaut resfinder and the nih
amr finder database into a single
point of entry and a consistent ontology
across the whole database as well
and that's also available in addition
you have access to
vrdb a widely used database
on virulence and pathogen genes
pathogenic genes
as well as aries genetics proprietary
aries db which is a collection of
antimicrobial resistance genes from over
100 different pathogens
that are all traceable back to their
clinical source
for metagenomics capabilities we as i
mentioned earlier we include both
amplicon and 16s or its targeted
microbiome profiling as well as de novo
assembly
and binning tools uh as well as
functional annotation tools for
functional metagenomics or functional
general explanations as well
and for our annotation tools we have
provided our
users with multiple approaches including
blast the diamond algorithm
there's also gene ontology
classification tools as well as
protein domain or keyframe domain
identification and predicted genes
for uh pathogen outbreak and tracing
purposes
um this is kind of a screenshot of what
the one of the views might look like
inside the workbench
and in this case here you're seeing a
minimum spanning tree
of cancel bacter isolates using the
traditional seven gene mlst
approach you have your tree in the upper
left-hand window here as well as a heat
map of
your different alleles as well as
vertically as well as
on all of the individual isolates
on the left side and a table that allows
you to quickly navigate the isolates of
interest
on the right here you see another type
of tree this is built from a base tree
on tuberculosis isolates from a recent
hospital outbreak that was published in
in the open literature and it also is
kind of a
snapshot of how you can tie metadata
that you might have associated with
individual isolates or strains
um to uh to any kind of phylogenetic
tree that you might build and in this
case
the researchers um were indicating you
know which isils are coming from austria
or germany or romania
et cetera um and the merging of our
fellow genetic tree tools with tables of
data with your metadata in it allows our
users to
customize their trees quite a bit to to
highlight the data that's relevant for
their
uh for their research and these links
here to a white paper and webinar where
you can dive deeper into these
capabilities
are live links and if you will provide
you with the slides later so you can go
ahead and click through and find these
they're also
available directly on our website as
well
the microbial genomics module also has
the ability to
detect and visualize antibiotic
resistance markers
using multiple approaches we have a
gene-based tool that
takes a gene database as input of amr
factors and then identifies
candidate amor genes using blast we also
have a
tool called uh point finder which is uh
it's an implementation of the point
finder algorithm
that's actually released by dtu in
denmark and uses their
uh databases as well which are directly
you can import into clc
and that tool identifies specific snips
or
um point mutations in um
in genes that would confer resistance uh
if they were mutated
classical example is um jayara hrb
for example and uh what we see here in
the this this screenshot of the clc is
our 3d um protein structure viewer in
the upper left-hand corner
with um the reference genome for
tuberculosis h37rv
and various tracks showing the different
genes here and in this
uh gene here that's visualized on the
genome there are certain point mutations
and this is in the gyre
gyra gene and we have loaded up the
actual gyra
protein structure model and you can
actually navigate
directly to this position in your model
um
through the variant table of where these
mutations are actually been identified
and this is a way of taking genomics
data and actually um
visualizing it in 3d space on your
protein structures to get a good idea of
sort of what the potential impact might
be in certain mutations
on this next slide you can see an
overview or microbiome tools
um which previously i mentioned that we
have taxonomic profiling
tools as well as de novo assembly and
annotation tools
for your assemblies and what you see
here is a screenshot of the genomics
workbench view
where in the upper left-hand corner you
can see an aggregate of taxonomics
abundance profiles
for a range of samples that are included
in a particular
research study a principal coordinate
analysis plot of those same samples
seeing sort of separation of the samples
to identify
potential groups of interest there is a
refraction curve
for from the alpha diversity analysis
tool that shows depth of sequencing
comparing the number of uh taxonomic
units identified and for each of the
individual samples we also
include a metagenomics report if you
will that
highlights the total number of species
genus found etc the depth of sequencing
and various other statistics associated
with the sample
it's important to note here that um this
tool set specifically for the
application of microbiome profiling has
been highlighted in two recent
publications
um that were review articles that
independently
uh concluded that the clc platform was
the best in class for
enabling microbiome research and links
to those articles were provided here as
well as linked to a research paper
white paper that we also released from
our own group
demonstrating its utility for um 16 s
robinson fungal its
analysis
it's also important to note that all
these tools are work
seamlessly with the rest of the genomics
workbench environment
which includes for example the ability
to rapidly build workflows
using our drag and drop interface this
is a snapshot of
[Music]
our databases that also work seamlessly
with microbial genomics module there's a
wide range of different types of
databases that you can access
um in the public domain as well as
proprietary databases that are from
uh kyogen that are available through the
clc
genomics workbench platform
in addition to the
microbial genomics module that's
included in the pro suite you also get
the clc genome finishing module
and this is a additional set of tools
that specifically enable
researchers who are doing whole genome
sequencing and de novo assembly
to create high quality enclosed uh
genomes or high quality trap genomes to
share with the rest of the research
community
it takes um the process of doing geneva
assembly and binning
and polishing of data um
really one one not step four but really
a leap forward in the sense that it
provides
genome assemblers or curators the
ability to
visualize their assemblies and manually
correct
uh chimeric uh contents and other
aspects of the genome assembly that
might have been in
error due to differences in the
sequencing data
or differences in chemistry that might
have been used pulling different
data together so in this view here you
can see the
content joining tool where the
researcher has
a specific content that he's uh created
in this case it's called joint
number three and what they've done is
the tool enables
the investigator to align multiple
contacts from an individual assembly at
the ends
and um you can use it with or without a
reference
as a backbone and and as a scaffold
to create sort of super assemblies or
larger scaffolds out of your individual
content
this can be done manually or it can be
done automated in an automated fashion
as part of a workflow as well and then
researchers can go back and correct
those assemblies
to further improve them before releasing
them we have
several video tutorials on how to use
these tools as well as a technical note
describing the features of the genome
finishing module in detail
so now i'll get to the real reason that
you're here which is to learn about
bacterial strain typing and genomics
characterization of multi-drug
resistance
using the clc microbial genomics model
so there are three major challenges that
are often faced by researchers
involved in microbial genomics research
whether you're in the public health
space
or clinical microbiology space or you're
in
the biotech uh basic research space
it's not uncommon to have a need for
high quality assemblies and annotation
of isolates the ability to
identify differences among your isolates
using strain typing
establish strain typing schemas
or in the absence of established uh
string typing schemas to be able to
develop your own methods
and your own schemas or to use a
reference free approach
um like a camera-based tool um
and also researchers are frequently
obviously interested in
characterizing the function of
different genes or groups of genes that
might be identified in their
in their isolation for example in the
case of antibiotic resistance markers or
virulence factors
and i'll be walking through each of
these uh use cases
um uh with uh campylobacter gigini
uh data that was obtained from a paper
and released on
sra so this is the paper where this data
comes from was published in 2017 where
they did a benchmarking of
mlst tools that are available in the
public domain
all of the data available for this paper
is um
is available on sequence read archive at
ncbi
and the clc generalized workbench
includes an integrated sra
sra query tool where you can
query for samples by sra number or by
biosample or even by bio project so
for example in this publication the bio
project accession number is listed
and all i had to do was simply use that
accession number to search
um it returned a list of the actual raw
sequencing data from that
that paper and then i was able to
download these results directly to my
laptop
it's a um a very convenient uh
aspect of the platforms that we do
directly tie into these public databases
in this brief tutorial what i'll be
doing is showing you how to download
data from sra
build an excel table of the metadata
associated with each of these individual
samples which i actually obtained from
the paper
um we'll download the chemical vector
mlst schema
we'll do a denoble assembly of the raw
data
uh do strain typing on those isolates
we'll characterize whether or not they
have
antimicrobial resistance genes and then
we'll build an automated workflow that
will
do everything i just mentioned from end
to end without
without any user interaction
so the first thing as i mentioned was
identifying
where to find data in the public domain
so within clc
under the download menu you'll notice
that we have a tool for searching reads
for raw reads on sra
searching for sequences for genbank or
ncbi they're like completed isolates for
protein sequences
specific genes etc you can also pull
down
protein structures or rna structures
from the protein data bank
um and you can also search for sequences
directly in uniprot
for proteins and things like that so in
this case i
um well the screenshot here shows i have
an individual
sample number that was um i'm querying
for and
after searching for that i was able to
identify the specific
uh raw sequencing data associated with
that sample
and it's just a matter of highlighting
the sample and clicking the download
button and then it goes ahead and it
downloads it to your local
your local machine
the next step would be to take the
metadata
and assign that metadata to your
individual um
samples within clc and the process to do
that actually starts out
in microsoft excel where
you would create a table of your data
where
every column in your table is different
fields of interest
um and every row in your table is the
different samples that you'll be doing
on your analysis
and the important thing about assigning
metadata to your samples
in clc is to make sure that at least
one of the columns in your metadata
table matches up
with the sequence name of the actual
files
or sequence reads that are being
analyzed so whether you've downloaded
them from sra or whether it's your own
sequencing data that you've imported
into clc from a recent sequencing run
you want to make sure that the actual
file name matches up with something in
the table that you're
you're importing once you have your
table constructed
it's a simple matter of launching the
import metadata tool which is under the
file menu
that prompts you with this window here
where you point to the excel file it
imports the data and
shows you the individual columns that
you're going to be importing
and then it will try to assign them to
um
data that you you basically point this
tool to a specific folder
or a specific set of files that are
already within imported within clc
sequence reads
and then the end result is that you'll
have a table within
clc that has a list of all your strains
it'll look exactly like what it looks
like in cl
in excel but the the major advantage
here is that you can actually
any subsequent experiments or results or
analysis that's done
on the samples that are associated with
metadata will be
all the those downstream files will be
automatically associated with this table
so you can use your metadata table as a
way of organizing your
project data and if you're looking for
specific
general assembly results or
variant calling results or something for
a particular sample
all you need to do is open up the
metadata in the future click on the row
of interest
and then um you would click on the find
associated
data button and it will immediately open
up a
um a link or a list of all the
associated
results and data that's that's um been
connected to that
row in your table
after i had imported all of my raw data
and the metadata associated with that
and create those associations the next
step in the
in the process which was for me to
download the mlst typing scheme for
campylobacter
so clc uh microbiologist module provides
connections directly to pubmlst.org
you can browse the existing mlst schemas
that are available through pubmlst and
download them directly into your
workbench to
for analysis and there's a huge range of
different
bacterial pathogens that are available
on
public lst in addition we also include
tools for you to create your own mlst
schemas if you have a non-model system
or some other bacteria or whatever that
is not in the public domain
you can use this our tools to actually
uh very quickly create
a cmos from scratch that then can be
reused for further analysis down the
road
um but in our case for campbell actor
we wanted to download the classic uh
mlst schema 7g
mlst schema and to do that we because we
have next-gen sequencing data and not
sanger data we use the tool
uh download mlst schema from publicity
under the ngs
mlst folder for core genome or whole
whole genome mlst where the schemas are
much larger
uh with many many more alleles
associated with them
um you would use the download large mlst
schema tool
under the large mst folder an easy way
to find these tools
uh just as a side note here and you can
of course
navigate through your tool menu and find
the tools but there's over 300 tools
included in clc
and sometimes it can be challenging to
find
the specific tool that you might need um
you can favorite tools and they will be
saved on your favorites tab if you just
switch over to that favorites tab you
would see them
another way to quickly find tools is
actually to use our quick launch button
so there's a button here at the top of
the view that if you click that it pops
up this little quick launch window
and if this is a free text search area
where you can type in
pretty much anything that you might
that's in the name of the tool that
you're looking for and it will quickly
filter the list down to only the tools
that match your search query
and this is a very convenient way to
quickly find tools
so i went ahead and downloaded the the
campylobacter
mlst typing schemes and then
went ahead and did analysis on uh these
these individual samples and i'll walk
through that a little bit further here
in a second
um so the traditional 17 mlst typing
school this is a
schema this is a view of what that looks
like up close
um we have a minimum spanning tree in
the upper left-hand corner here
there's a heat map of the different the
seven different alleles as well as all
of the isolates
and you can actually um this is
interactive um
where you can click on this in this um
uh
hierarchical clustering heat map and it
will actually highlight
the specific isolates in the tree on the
left
you can also open up a table of your
trees to look for specific
sequence types of interest which is
often of interest to clinical
microbiologists
and when you click one or more of those
isolates in your table it will
um there's a button here that says
select sequence types in other views
clicking that button will then highlight
those isolates in your tree as well
and as a brief introduction to how that
works
here we are in clc
go ahead and just make this window a
little bit larger
and um let's see here
we'll open up the heat map that i was
showing a moment ago
i'll put that over here in this uh in
this window
so let's drag that here
please
there we go and uh just show you some of
the interactive aspects of the way this
tool works
sorry the go to meeting toolbar is
actually in the way
there it is so you can change coloring
and so forth of your heat map of
interest
i can highlight various things uh like
this
and then for example if i had a specific
isolate that i was looking for in the
table and i clicked this here you'll
notice
that's found in this larger cluster here
but let's try another one
uh i'll see 48 maybe no it's a 416
okay well just try it out a little bit
further
a lot of these are actually found these
sequence types seem to be found in the
same
that central cluster there so if i were
to drop this down
you'll see that this window actually
will expand
and there's a bit of an animation here
as the
software sort of figures out um the
optimal distances to keep all these
clusters separate and
um looks to me as though
all these isolates are actually found in
that central cluster so let me just
scroll down here a bit
and well
in any case if i were to then do it the
other way
where i were to highlight for example a
region out here
i could select these in other views and
you'll notice
that over here the heat map updated
uh and it also it also highlighted those
same
uh isolates in the table whereas the
photos for example
let's say highlight uh let's let's say
this cluster here
uh and i again click this again it will
take me to that location on the table of
where these sequence types are located
and also then
change the view of the actual um a heat
map where you can see that there are
actually
um rows now that have been selected that
are um
allow you to further investigate that so
then if you had a specific outbreak that
was associated with a particular cluster
you could then um create a sub cluster
or sub scheme
out of this mlst schema um instantly by
just clicking this button here and it
will then
uh basically create an entirely new um
mlst schema file that would allow you to
then add
or do more comparative analysis down the
road um
so i'll switch back to my presentation
okay so
now we see uh uh
a uh our work our workflow uh editor
over here on the right
and this is specifically for in this
example what i'm doing is i'm
uh creating a simple workflow that does
re-trimming
uh some quality control analysis of my
input data and then does it to noble
assembly where the
um the draft assembly is one of the
outputs as well as a number of different
reports
um this is a kind of a first step
towards actually doing strain typing on
all of your isolates
there's a couple of different ways that
you can run workflows on
multiple samples when you launch a
workflow you'll have an
option to run it in batch mode which
means that it will run that same
workflow one time
on all of the input samples that you are
submitting to the workflow there's
another way that you can run workflows
now which is a new way that we
introduced in the most recent release of
the clc platform
which is we introduced two new tools
that are flow control tools uh for our
workflow editor
one is the iterate tool and the other is
the collect and distribute tool
and i wanna encourage uh the
participants in this webinar to
read up on these tools in our
documentation i won't go into details
about them here but
um i will say that these tools allow you
to
run multiple samples through a single
workflow
where the workflow itself only actually
runs once and the control
of what sections of workflow actually
iterate or become loops if you will
and when data is collected from multiple
samples and then distributed to
a consolidated report is
something that is controlled by the user
when they create the workflow
or can be controlled by a metadata table
depending on
what the needs are and a simple example
would be if you were to
let's say you were doing um uh rna-seq
analysis
uh for gene expression and you wanted to
compare
control versus experimental data or you
had a time series you might
want to have um different
sets of data being drawn through a
workflow analyzed slightly differently
um depending on whether or not the
the those individual samples were you
know part of the control set or part of
the experimental
set um or a specific time point for
example
and your metadata tables can control
that and control the behavior of these
iterate
and um collect and distribute tools that
can be included in your workflows
it's very powerful
so the running this the workflow i had
created
produced a number of reports including
uh a qc
report which um we're only showing a a
small one
section of here um in this view this is
a view of the quality distribution of
the
reads going in a trimming report of the
reads prior to the actual assembly
um assembly report that kind of shows
the quality
of the assembly itself including
scaffolding regions since where the n50
was and the number of contacts and so
forth
and then you can actually open up the
assembly itself of course and you can
see a list of the 136 contags and each
of these
are essentially read mappings that can
be further opened
and you can investigate how the reads
were mapped and
what areas of those contexts had low
coverage etc
once i had completed all of the de novo
assemblies of the samples that were
obtained from that paper
um running the strain typing tool um
on on those assemblies produced a number
of reports
uh one of them for example is this um
this is the strain type you report for
those traditional seven gene mlst
um uh tool which uh identifies the
allele itself
what the specific sequence was for that
sequence type and
uh whether it matched or not and what
the depth of coverage was for the match
that was hit
and what the uh was the highest quality
sequence type that was identified
so we don't uh necessarily return only a
single result
what i mean by that is you do see a
single result at the top of this report
but if you actually open up
the output of the mlst tools as a table
you'll see a rank ordering of all the
sort of second and third best
uh potential sequence types that might
be assigned to an individual
sample and in this case um the score of
1.0 is as high as you can get and
sequence type 8 was assigned
which is correct over here with the
cgmlst tools
we also came to the same conclusion that
this was uh sequence type number eight
um and uh this this particular report
also has some coloring
uh highlights green as being the best um
the best hit and this is a view of the
actual minimum spanning tree where
we've selected uh this sequence type in
this table here
we clicked the button select types and
other views and it highlighted
where in the actual tree
[Music]
those sequence types are actually
located
which would be helpful if you were doing
comparative analysis to other
isolates for example during an outbreak
i mentioned earlier that we for moving
on to
antimicrobial resistance
characterization i mentioned earlier
that
kyogen has a database that we call the
kind of microbial insights ar
database this is an integration of the
comprehensive antibiotic
antimicrobial resistance database or
card restfinder
argonaut and the nih's amr finder
database
um it's important to note that um
res finder argonaut and amr finder do
not
have a structured and ontology
associated with antibiotic resistance
genes
but card does and it was important to us
to maintain
um a structure in that way an ontology
so we actually re-implemented cards
ontology and we'll continue to maintain
the ontology that card uses
and we applied it to all of the other
genes that were pulled
from these other databases in our
integrated database as well qmiar
and this is a one view of the database
itself where we have
a list of different markers we
have kind of a you can say a
source or an origin identifier where we
indicate which database
this particular gene was originated from
you'll notice that um
some genes are found in card and not in
others and
if i were to scroll through this table
you would see that there are
um there's quite a lot of diversity or
disparity i should say between the
overlap between these different
databases not all
genes are found in all databases i mean
the whole point of why we pull this
database together
we also add um pubmed ids for each gene
in qmiar where these are live links or
if you were to click these they'll take
you out to the original literature that
was the original citation for when this
gene was discovered and when it was
deposited into the card
which is helpful for researchers when
they want to investigate specific
uh genes that might be conferring
resistance
in addition we also provide access to
the aries
aries db from aries genetics and as i
mentioned earlier this consists of
amr markers that have been identified
through machine learning methods from
over 11 000 clinical isolates resistant
pathogens
the um important thing to note uh
about aries db is that all the isolates
in aries db come from
human clinical
sources and they all have been
empirically tested
uh for antibiotic susceptibility
and then whole genome sequencing was
done using a consistent method
the assembly pipelines were all
consistent and
the annotation pipelines were all
consistent across all the isolates in
aries db
um and so access to areas db provides
our users the ability to identify genes
some are
known antibiotic resistance genes not
surprisingly others
and many however are novel and not in
the uh
in these other public databases we also
provide uh mic values
and um likelihood scores associated with
uh how likely is an individual marker
that we've identified in aries db is
actually conferring resistance
um so there's kind of a breakdown here
the number of different genes and snips
that we've identified that
aries genetics has identified that we've
included in this database for you to
investigate further
on the algorithm side um
[Music]
for amr prediction we have a find
resistance uh nucleotide database tool
the uh find resistance with point finder
and
find resistance with shortbread tools
and these have
different inputs and different outputs
depending on the type of data that you
you're working with and types of
analysis that you need
define resistance with nucleotide
database tool requires context
or whole genomes as input and it'll
identify genes
conferring resistance to really any gene
database that you provide but it's
it's intended to be used with one of the
databases that we provide is download
but
you of course can create your own as
well the fine resistance with point
finder
uh is run on raw data and it then
compares that to
a very highly well curated database of
point mutations that's maintained by dtu
in denmark
and then the output of that is a table
of resistance markers and specific snips
that are associated with with resistance
the shortbread tool which anecdotally is
one of my favorites also runs on raw
reads
and this uses what's called a short red
database which is a database of
pre-compiled protein markers
that are designed these are
antibiotic resistance gene or proteins
and the specific markers associated with
resistance that are
not found in uh any other genes
other than these resistance genes and so
you run your raw reeds
through the shortbread pipeline and it
will take those reads out
that have a high level of similarity or
would be predicted
to have a high level of similarity to
dna that would encode these specific
protein markers so it's a way of using
protein data
on protein markers to actually query
your genomic data
um so especially for hypothesis
generation and the ability to identify
novel uh antibiotic resistance markers
shortbread i think does an excellent job
at this because of the
um sort of inherent flexibility of um
dna sequence as it as it gets translated
into into protein sequence right so
it's a very broad range there and it's
it's a great way to identify new markers
that
might not otherwise be present in the
databases themselves
so here's a simple workflow where your
raw data is coming in
we do saw a trimming cell up front and
then after trimming the reeds we run
those raw reads through shortbread
and through point finder we then do a
denoble assembly on those reeds
and then after the assembly is completed
we run those assemblies through the fine
resistance with nucleotide database
so this is a simple workflow that takes
raw fsq files as input
and the output is a analysis using three
different antibiotic resistance
methods as to whether or not your
isolate actually has resistance genes
and specifically where they are
and what the nature is this is a
snapshot of
uh what some of the outputs might look
like in clc
um in the upper left-hand corner you
have the output of our
gene finding tool where in this case
there were five different genes that
were identified
their level of similarity to what was in
the database um the length of the match
and so forth the specific context that
they were identified on etc
um in the upper right hand corner uh
these are reeds that were
i you could say word will bend in other
words they had a high level of
similarity to
known antibiotic resistance genes um
that were pulled out using the point
finder tool um
the lower left corner uh this is a list
of um
potential drug resistance phenotypes
that were identified in your sample
um and uh the
number of um uh hits
that were assigned to each one of those
now a note here for those who are
sort of eagle-eyed you'll notice that a
lot of these sort of generically say
antibiotic molecule
um and this is because the underlying
phenotypic
uh ontology that this actually
phenotypic aro number that's assigned to
these
um in the card database that has uh
identical
names so this is a known issue that
we're addressing in a next
a new release in the near future that
will have a better resolution here on
the actual uh title here so don't be uh
don't be scared off now but if you were
to click through
and um uh follow these links to your
uh with your web browser you would see
indeed that um
what the specific antibiotic resistance
markers were and what the drugs were
that were associated with those
so bringing this all together you have a
single workflow here that does
raw fast q files up front as input
we trim the reeds we do a denotable
assembly on those reeds
and we can find antibiotic resistance
genes and also do our qc
the raw rates themselves um then can as
i mentioned earlier which can be run
into our point finder tool or a
shortbread tool for antibiotic
resistance genes
as well as serving as input into our
cgmlst tool set where we can
identify string typing in a
assembly free manner and actually um
add that if a new typing a new string
type has been identified
actually add that type to uh to a schema
database that you're currently using
and i haven't covered it here in this
presentation but
uh directly from this denoble assembly
uh step in this workflow you can also
see that we're identifying new genes
and finding prokaryotic genes in our
assemblies and
we're analyzing those genes with diamond
um and
providing a functional assessment and
classification of those genes
and then we're applying um an analysis
of pfam domains
and gene ontology or go annotations as
well be applied
and this enables researchers to take
into novel assembly
identify genes and then do a functional
classification
um on what sort of other um genomic
or genetic capabilities or
features are present in the in the
organism of interest
so today um as a brief review uh
we kind of overviewed some of the
capabilities of the clc genomics pro
suite
specifically really kind of went into
detail about the microbial genomics
module as it relates to strain typing
and strain characterization for amr
we learned how to download data from sra
use excel uh
as a starting point for importing
metadata and then assigning that
metadata to your actual samples in clc
we uh reviewed how to download mlst
schemas do general assemblies and strain
typing
as well as work with our antimicrobial
resistance
uh databases and analysis tools and
lastly and importantly
um one of the strengths of the clc
platform is the ability to build
single workflows that automate the
entire process from from one end to the
other
one other final comment i'll make here
um is
the underlying databases that we are
using throughout this
tutorial are customizable
so in pretty much every instance
users can download data directly from
genbank or
other public resources directly within
clc or if there are other databases that
you may have access to
or other public resources that have uh
draft assemblies or genomes that you
want to work with
um you can of course uh import those
into clc directly as well
um without using our integrated tools
but just using our standard importers to
create your own customized databases
and um this is this capability of
building
flexible microbial genomics databases is
really a strength of the platform
because
you can reapply this for microbiome
profiling on the fly
um you can also maintain and update your
own mlst schemas for isolates
et cetera there's a lot of applications
on the database
side and customization side that many
many folks find very useful
so for more information there's a link
here to our microbial genomics
portion of our research and discovery
portfolio
and uh thank you thank you very much for
your time
please feel free to contact us if you
have any further questions